how'd you get the name butter
um that's my nickname wife from family
since a kid or since you were working
the streets since that was the case
yeah all right butter where are you from
where'd you grow up
um i grew up in like carson california
and then as i grew older i moved to
englewood california
and uh tell me about your family growing
up yeah both your parents
yeah i was with my mom growing up my mom
my dad separated but it's like
you know my mom was a good mom she did
everything she could she was a stripper
for like 20 years so how was your
childhood any abuse any
traumatic events no child abuse
and like no like at the end of the day
when my grandma and grandpa died that's
when life right really
got hard for my mama because like she
was adopted and stuff so at the end of
the day
that's like the most dramatic thing that
happened when my grandparents died
so how far did you go to school um
i made it to the 11th grade well i made
it to the 12th but
i ended up going to jail and i never
like completed it
you started working the street at what
age at 15
15. yeah how'd you do that um you meet
somebody
yeah i met some guy and basically like
he just was taking care of me like what
i thought he was taking care of me like
grooming me and
he taking me to the nail shop and stuff
and then he took me to
a place and he was like god you need to
get out and make some money to prove
that you cared for me
and that's like where it all went down
so he was out operating basically as a
pimp yeah or a
boyfriend hustler well he was my
boyfriend i thought like he was my
negative because i was like 15
not even about to be sixteen so i was
just
experiencing guys so yeah
do you remember your very first time
picking up a trick uh-huh do you
remember your very first time picking up
a
john yeah when that when i was down for
him
who was your first customer i went to
jail my first time you did
yeah that was serious it was a cop
yeah it was undercover oh wow i don't
suppose it
and are drugs a part of your life um
yeah we
i used to do cocaine nothing else
no you sure i'm positive
and uh today you're working on your own
or with a today i'm working on my own
you are yeah and how was that
it's it's okay working on your own
because like
any day you could see more of your money
and you could benefit off of it more if
you just do the right things but
right now for me it's been hard because
i just
left the situation with a pimp so
i'm just starting over right what are
the advantages or disadvantages of
both the advantages are they going to
the pimp's gonna always be on call when
you need him he's going to take you to
the money
and the disadvantage is nothing that you
have
or you worked for you sold your [ __ ]
for you sucked it for is yours
you don't get to keep none of it when
you leave you're going to leave a jacket
and maybe the shoes on your feet and if
you get lucky the wig on your head so
that's the advantages and disadvantages
and doing it on your own you get to keep
your money
you do get to keep your own money but at
the end of the day like i have reckless
spending problems like
i don't know how to manage my money so
i'm i could i could own the house
already
but i'm like trying to live like i'm
rich
do you have a boyfriend now no i don't
it's hard to have a boyfriend doing this
kind of work right
yeah like someone takes me serious yeah
very few guys will put up with a girl
that's doing this kind of work right
you right i've only had one serious
relationship and how did that go
it went good you know right of course
and um
it's actually my baby's father's day
he's in jail he's in jail yeah
do you have kids yeah i want y'all
and are you raising him or her um yeah
i'm raising her
along with my family
what emotions does this lifestyle bring
up for you
um for me it makes me like lonely
and it just makes me like kind of
not i'm gonna say heartless because i
wear my feelings on
my sleeve but it makes me just not pay
attention it makes me aware it makes me
feel like this [ __ ] is okay and i know
it's really not
so deep down you know that this is
probably not the best lifestyle for you
yeah but there's no other options for
you is that what you feel
i feel like this is the best thing i'm
good at
you've had bad experiences out there
doing it yeah i've had quite a few
what kind of stuff has happened well um
i've never got raped before by a guy
like a trick or anything
or john or whatever you call them but at
the end of the day like
i've got robbed at gunpoint while doing
the job
or i've had guys like you date black
guys but you're not supposed to
and then they gave you the money the
honey that's 150 or 200 and then
if one thing don't go right they want to
take your money and then it's like
what i worked for for one i worked for
and then for two now i just told this
pimp that i'm paying and i got this
amount of money and i don't have nothing
to show for the amount of time that i
was with the john
so it's like so that's a bad experience
the pimps you've had i've advised you
not to go with black eyes
not all of them but you could like most
of them have like yeah
yeah what's the hardest part of
doing this kind of work being away from
my baby yeah
what mistakes have you learned from in
doing this are the things you've learned
that
like oh my i wish i knew that earlier on
i'm still learning but at the end of the
day i just
wish i learned learn sooner like
basically just not to trust people and i
already knew that but
i could see so i see i was seeing stuff
before it be
like even happening and then i'd be in a
situation that i didn't want to be in so
how old are you now 27 27
what was the best time in your life um
the best time in my life was november 19
then i had my baby
that's always every every mother's
answer is the same i have my daughter on
my birthday on december 19th
but i had her a month early on the event
november 19th
and she was still healthy and everything
so it's a blessing
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about about girls that do this
kind of work
oh um or about you
what it is about you the most
misunderstanding most understood thing
about me is that people just think that
like
i think i'm all that and they think that
i don't know the most misunderstood
thing is like i don't know i guess
i don't try to portray to be perfect but
i just love myself
and i take myself into consideration and
it's like people behaving me
and like they don't be liking me or
treating me how i treat them
because i'll give to like a lot of
people but people like me trying to step
on me or like they
think i'm weak or something like you you
understand that 99
of hate is is just envy yeah we talked
about that before we
started oh yeah
and what's been the worst time in your
life um
the worst time in my life was when my
baby daddy went to jail no
in in july of 2016 one day
the feds came and knocked him in the
door and like ransacked the house and
everything and all that
and my baby was three years old at the
time
so i became a single mother in that
instant
how do you think working this kind of
life doing this
kind of work has changed you
it's made me very blunt and like
sometimes i don't take people feeling
there's a consideration
and i'll be self-centered
like yeah you can see that this life is
crazy right
yeah very dangerous lifestyle
for a girl right it is and i'm not just
saying that to agree
like yes it is because i'm living it
do you think it builds your self-esteem
or undermines it or does both
um it just depends on who you surround
yourself with
if you weak and you surround yourself
around a pimp or something that's gonna
pull you down and tear you down
that's what it's gonna be but i don't
know
it's hard to answer yeah do you still
believe in love
no uh-uh
i know i be falling in love fast with it
it's less it's not love
yeah i don't believe in love period
what kind of things does a girl need to
know before she gets into this kind of
life what would you advise the young
girls that's thinking about it
just don't pay no guy
if you want to get into it or whatever
if you want to get into it don't get
into it like you know i don't even
promote it
to dead ass series like it's different
shows for different folks like me
i'm just a regular i'm a woman but i'm
trying to like get some money and i've
been
knowing how to do it so at the end of
the day money attracted me
so i don't i don't know but it's
different shows for different folks
do you think you're addicted to it um
yeah probably because i'd be like if i'm
poor i'm like i'm about to go
here like you know and like who just
goes to hang out on the blade but i'm
not hanging out like i'll be really it
is i want some money
oh it's just thirsty like but it ain't
thirsty i'm thirsty for money
yeah it makes it hard to get out yes i
see myself as being
like not a millionaire or like or like
you know
the thing that's under a millionaire
like i see myself having a lot of things
and like i have had things so
i don't know i want to have better for
myself and for my daughter yeah
do you get rich you know risky things
that the guys
that john's want to do with you all the
time with no condoms and
i'm not doing that but you like his
fetishes and all that and
i could be doing that [ __ ] but no
i'm not sucking dick with no condom
risking you could get herpes on your lip
from second deck putting a condom on it
with your mouth trying to be cute
so excuse me what's the most important
lesson you've learned
just be aware of the guy that you're
dating
in light you don't need to have like no
harm girls in the game
because these [ __ ] ain't your friends
basically
all right butter well thank you so much
for sharing your story and i wish you
the best of luck hope you're hoping you
get to spend as much time as you need to
with your daughter
okay and i appreciate you for even
taking your time out today to
interview me and talk to me oh thank you
i love hearing your stories
i hope it's genuine because like
i got nymph going on yeah no it's always
nice when somebody's honest and open and
yeah and i really was right yeah awesome
thank you darling thank you